um so what i'd like to talk about today
is a fault tolerance with ldpc codes and
i'll explain what an ldp ski code is
um so this is going to be kind of an
overview
mostly of work that's been done in the
past few years by people other than me
although i did i did do one thing that
kind of kick-started this area and so
so i'll talk about that as well um
and because it's an overview and talking
on a bunch of things it's going to be
fairly light on technical detail but i'm
happy to try to answer
more technical questions if they arise
um okay first how do i advance
okay there we go um so
the the the main thing that
you need to worry about um for the
purpose of this talk is that
quantum computers will probably need
some sort of error correction to work
so why is that well um qubits are
very very small generally maybe single
atoms or
you know small superconducting rings um
and so small things are of course
inherently
more susceptible to being bumped and
changing their state than than larger
things
so small bits or small qubits are
certainly going to be noisier than large
ones
um and in order to be quantum they need
to be small so that's one factor
the other factor is that there's more
things that can go wrong with a
qubit than with a classical bit right
you have uh
not just to worry about bit flips where
zero changes to one
but also phase flips zero plus one
changes to zero minus one
and one um uh version of face flipping
is something called g coherence
which happens when the environment
learns about the state of the system
and so that's something that really is
unique to quantum mechanics if
you know you read a bit in the classical
computer that doesn't shank you at all
but in a quantum computer it does
communicate and that's something that's
going on
all the time any any atom in the
environment can potentially learn a
little bit
about the state of the quantum system
and therefore cause a little bit of
error
and that's happening all the time and
that's something we really need to
get rid of and to correct for if we want
to build a big quantum computer
so the the central result in the theory
of fall tolerance is the threshold
theorem the fractional theorem
says in its uh original uh version
that if the error rate for gate and time
step is below some threshold value
the the threshold p sub t is is some
sort of universal constant
um then uh in that case you can use
coding with volatility protocols to
reduce
the uh the error rate to arbitrarily
small on the logical state
and to do so the overhead is only
polynomial in the log of the size of the
computation
and and the error rate that you'll find
received
so okay so um what goes into a fault
tolerant protocol
well um the first thing we need is a
quantum error correcting code so we're
going to encode
um some number of qubits k in a larger
number of qubits
at n and so the k qubits that we're
starting with are the logical qubits
we're not actually physically encoding
them but they're going to be
present in a distributed fashion in our
quantum computer
um and those k qubits are the ones in
which
we're performing our quantum algorithm
and then there's n physical qubits that
are actually realized
in the in your your quantum device
and um those are the ones that are
experiencing error
and we want this quantum error
correcting code to have the ability that
you know even if there's errors on a few
qubits or a small
fraction of the qubits physical qubits
in the final computer
we can correct those and um the
the logical qubits will be insulated and
have a very low
effective error rate um so
so uh two fact two features that we want
out of this quantum equipment code is
that
we don't need too many extra cubics the
the
rate k over n is relatively high
obviously it can't be higher than one
but um we'd like it to be as fine as
possible
um and the next thing of course is that
we want it to be
good at collecting errors so so when i
say you know
some fraction of the qubits go wrong say
each qubit has an error with probability
p
um so then there's about p n errors uh
in the system on a typical uh case
and so we'd like p to be as large as
possible
um but then the third thing is that we
want to be able to do this
and have an efficient classical
algorithm
that when there's an error we can deduce
what that error is
and and correct it or at least
compensate for it
um and so people have come up with lots
of quantum air correcting codes and some
of them
uh certainly satisfy all these these
conditions um
but the problem is that to build a
quantum computer we need to go beyond
that we also need
a way of doing all the error correction
procedure
when there's errors in the procedure
itself and that's much harder so
you need a fault tolerant error
correction procedure um and moreover we
need
ways to do the the computation without
losing the protection against arrows so
we need
both hauling gate constructions we need
to be able to prepare the initial states
and and other ancillary states that we
need during computation in a fall
tolerant way
we need to measure the full-time rate um
and so uh i think it's fair to say that
that most of the codes that people are
very seriously considering
for building a fault tolerant one
computer are
some version of ldpc codes and ldpc
stands for low density particles
so let me tell you what an ldpc code is
and why we want it and that's gonna
um and yeah
and so the the ldpc code is a class
in the class of stabilizer codes i'm not
really going to explain what stabilizer
codes are
but um they have two additional
properties so
stabilizer codes you have a bunch of
constraints that are that are
tensor products of polys um and
uh in the ldbc code um each of those
constraints with each element of
stabilize each generator stabilizer
involves only a constant number of
qubits and then each
qubit is involved in only a constant
number of constraints
so probably many of you are familiar
with possible linear coding so
stabilizer codes are kind of the quantum
version of linear code
and classical ldbc codes are just saying
that um each each parity check
as only a constant number of bits and
each bit isn't in a constant number of
priorities
um and so why do i say that uh ldpc
codes are
are the leading candidates for fall
tolerance well the real leading
candidate for fall tolerance right now
is a family of codes called surface
codes and they're an example of ldpc
codes
so so why do we want to do this well the
reason is that when we
do this fault tolerant error correction
procedure it's helpful to be only
have to collect a small number of qubits
at a time
um and so so ldp c codes to do that
uh so i'll elaborate on that more in a
minute but
um but i i guess i want to comment
that um the reason that i don't want to
just stop at surface codes
is that while surface codes are very
good they have a number of good
properties
um ldpc codes that are not surface codes
can potentially have a higher rate
and therefore they do a better job at
meeting one of those criteria that i was
i was asking for before
so okay so fault tolerant air corruption
so there's kind of three main methods of
fall tolerant aircraft
um some of the most efficient methods
really are
are methods due to skein and nil and the
thing is that
skein error correction and no air
correction um
both use very large gancilla states
and so you have to spend a lot of work
making those pencil states but then once
you've done that
you can very rapidly interact with the
code block
the art correcting code that you're
using for your computation and
extract the information that you need so
they're actually really
really very good very efficient error
correction procedures
but the problem is that they use
um code blocks which are the same really
the same code
as the one that you're using so if you
want to get an efficient
error correction procedure um you're
gonna use a
uh sorry an efficient error correcting
code you're gonna use a very big code
block
and uh that means that the incisions
that you make will have to also be great
with it
and that means that it really is a lot
of extra work in order to build those
big answers
so that's something that we kind of like
to avoid
um and so then comes the the third uh
family of
of fault procedures uh which is the the
shore
fault tolerant air correction so sure is
actually the the first
uh error correction procedure known as
original paper on fault tolerance
and then what you're going to hear about
next week that flagpole tolerance
is um sort of a basically a refinement
of four error correction which uses
uh fewer qubits um and has ways of
checking errors
anyway so so through our correction uses
um uh entangled states in the case of a
flag
two bits just single uh single and slow
qubits
um and the number of gates that you need
to do this
uh for each bit of the syncron which is
the
to gain one bit of information about the
error um
is is proportional to the the weight of
the
stabilization the weight of the
constraints that you have in your code
so if you have an arbitrary quantum
error correcting code an arbitrary
stabilizer code
that way it will be very high if you
have a large block and so through our
correction and flag perfection are not
good choices
but if you use an ldpc code
then there are a for our or our
correction or flag characteristic is a
good choice because
the the the size of the generator is
small and so we only need to touch a
small number of
um and the reason you want to touch many
qubits is because well if you have all
of these gates
and some of them are going wrong then
the odds of getting through
one measurement of one bit of the
syncron without having any errors is
very small
um whereas if it's a small size then
you have a pretty good chance of getting
through now you do in your fault tall
and error correction procedures have to
take account of the fact
that some of your synchro bits will be
wrong um
and i'm not really going to talk about
that but that's a condition to keep in
mind
but there are ways of doing that for
some codes anyway
um okay so so so we've decided that we
want to use ldpc code so what what do we
have available well
um one code as i said that's very
popular or one family of codes is the
surface code
so surface code is um an ldpc code
which is based on a graph that's on a
surface true to maximal surface
so um so for instance in the in the
figure here i've drawn
a uh you know a square lattice
and um the uh
the qubits in this lattice are located
on the edges
of the lines um and then
the stabilizer generators the
constraints for this ldpc code
are based on the plaquettes the squares
the two-dimensional
faces of this lattice and on the virtual
vertices
and they're different kinds so each face
has a
constraint x x x and what that means is
that the state the code word state has
to be a plus one eigen state of
x x x x around this phuket and each
vertex has a stabilizer generator z
z z z z for the four edges touching that
vertex
um and uh those those
constraints for all the vertices and all
the claquettes of this lattice
define the code the code is the set of
all states
that satisfy all of these constraints
and so it turns out
that in this code the logical qubits
which is also the the smallest error
that can
change a code word to a different code
word um
correspond to topologically non-trivial
paths
so for instance if the surface is
actually the surface of a torus
that we're connecting the opposite sides
of the square
then the logical qubits are associated
with loops that go around the torus
in a non-contractual way and so there's
two different sec
uh loops there's many there's many
groups but most of them are
topologically equivalent
so there's kind of two in equivalent
ones well we're kind of
a third one that's doing both of them so
so this code
on a tourist has two log computers
and in general if you do a different
surface the surface with boundaries it's
going to have a number of logical qubits
that's associated to some topological
property which is basically a constant
depending on how
in invariant more or less on how big the
lattice is
um but the distance depends on how far
it is to get around and it's that
there's n
q bits and this could be an o of n to
the one half
it's um then uh the the distance is
the square root of n so um
okay so so so why do we like surface
codes well one reason is that it turns
out
that even though the distance is only um
square root of n
and qubits it's pretty good at
correcting typical errors errors that
occur randomly
um if say each qubit has a has an error
with probably
p um and and uh
so that's a very good thing because that
means that the threshold
error rate that we need um in order to
make our fault tolerance work
is pretty high like in the vicinity of
one percent thank you if you have to
polarize things
so that's good because that sets uh the
the threshold of the code found that you
use
sets uh constraint on what the
experimentalists have to do in order
to make this thing work it has to get
below that threshold otherwise air
correction is not going to help
and actually recruit more than it helps
so the next really nice property of this
this surface code is that it has a
two-dimensional layout right it's if
if you obviously if you do it on a
tourist that's a little awkward but if
you do it on a
on a flat surface and use some
boundaries to create the topological
effects
um then only uh you can you can put it
in a flat thing and only nearby
qubits need to interact with each other
so that's something that in a lot of
systems
is much easier to do than having qubits
that are far apart
um and then finally there's a lot of
gate
uh uh constructions that have been
and have been devised for the surface
code um some use
code deformation where you change the
the lattice to
uh modify the way the log qubits are
are done um others you know have
different surfaces that you can kind of
tie together by doing some operations
and then
cut them apart again in different ways
and you can do a lot of a lot of gates
that way
um and those things don't don't uh
break this true dimensional layout
property and they don't use excessive
extra overhead
now there are some other gates that
require some more overhead and that's
that's
still a bit of a problem but it's not
one you know how to avoid in any system
really
um and um
that that's not true there's some
there's some specific codes we know that
can avoid
that but they have other drawbacks so
it's kind of a trade-off
um in any case the um the
the surface codes however not perfect
and so
the big problem with them is that they
need relatively lot of overhead
so they satisfy the threshold theorem
that i said before which is that the
scaling of the overhead is not too bad
it's a polynomial in the logarithm
of the size of the computation you want
to do but in practice
for for even you know relatively modest
computations you're gonna need hundreds
or thousands of physical qubits for
every log computer
okay so that's that's kind of annoying
because
well it means that you know if you have
a thousand physical qubits which sounds
like a lot
to a modern experimentalist um
you still might only have a handful of
logical qubits not enough to do anything
that's interesting in the sense of
getting a speed up over a
possible computation and if you can get
a million
million physical qubits well then maybe
finally you're starting to get to the
point
where you can you can do something that
you can do possibly
um so that's that's one problem that
we'd like to
overcome and another problem which is
less serious is that
there's while there's been a lot a lot
of work that's gone into
classical decoding algorithms for the
synchronous surface codes
um they're still a bit slow in practice
um
and so uh so that's something that could
see some further improvement either by
finding better
uh algorithms through surface code or by
finding other codes that have
better decoding
okay so um
what other options do we have we said we
wanted to use ldpc codes
so let's try to find an ldpc code that
has a better rate
on how efficient a code that's laid out
in two dimensions can possibly be
and so in order to do that we're going
to have to go outside of two dimensions
so we're gonna have to give up that
property
um so so one family of codes is actually
still surface codes but now they're not
on a flat surface they're on a
hyperbolic surface
and it turns out that if you pick you
know clever hyperbolic surfaces with
weird connectivity that you can achieve
this goal of having
a constant rate k over n as n gets large
um and as the logical error rate gets
very
small um but the problem is that the
distance
and those codes is only log n so it does
increase with n
but very slowly and that means that the
logical error rate
while it's suppressed as n gets larger
and larger um
is is is only dropping polynomial with n
rather than exponentially then what you
normally see so i notice that there's
some
questions in the q a um
let's see the surface codes allow qubit
recycling
um i'm not completely sure what you mean
by that but
uh the the
the surface codes if you're doing say
um lattice surgery then you you might
have you know two bits
of logical cubit over here and some
ancillary qubit over here in protein
surface code you apply them together
using this lattice library
and then cut them apart later and then
these qubits can be reset
into a new and so on that's certainly
certainly possible
um and then second question are domestic
passing decoders for surface codes or
other
uh ldpc codes as there are possible lgbt
codes
so um uh moreover if we want to use
density evolution for asymptotic
or not so i'm not sure what density
evolution is so i'm not going to answer
that question
um so there are message passing decoders
that people have worked on
but there's actually a major uh
complication
and so they don't really work as well
for
for quantum ldpc codes as they do for
possible ldpc codes
and the reason for that is something
called degeneracy
so um in a quantum code you can have
this phenomenon
where um you do
some some set of different errors
well some some set of operations some
set of errors essentially or
or bit flips or something like that to
the code word and get back to the
original code word
um that doesn't happen classically and
the
what that means in terms of domestic
passing
is that you'll have different sets of
errors that are equivalent
um and um and so if you do some sort of
belief propagation algorithm
that it tends to get confused on these
what this translates to
is is you have in the um in the channel
graph you have small
uh loops which is something that causes
these these messy passing decoders to
fill
um and so you have to do something a bit
more clever in the quantum case but i'll
talk about the putting algorithms
okay so um
daniel can i ask you a very quick
question a little confusion in the q a
so in the definition of quantum ldpc
that you
gave is being a stabilizer part of the
definition
because then towards the end of the
slide you said if you relax stabilizers
you might get better rate i got a little
bit confused about that
um right so uh
yeah so so so usually
i mean i think it's fair to say that
usually
it's part of the definition of an ldpc
code
um people have also looked at codes um
where their ground states is some local
hamiltonian
where the hamiltonian is the sum of
terms each of which
um is is is low weight
and um so that's kind of like an ldpc
code so if each of those terms is a is a
poly
and the the hamiltonian is unfrustrated
so there's the ground state
which is an eigen state of each term
individually
then that that is in fact a stabilizer
code um but if you don't satisfy
both of those constraints then it would
be something that's not a stabilizer
code and
there's some possibility of looking at a
code like this that might have similar
properties to an ldpc code
i think in most cases people do not
actually call them ldpc codes
but um but but they might have some of
these same properties that launch and
still
uh uh circumvent some of the
difficulties we have
but but in any case there's been a lot
of progress
in in recent years as i'm going to tell
you about on just you know
stabilizer codes and ldpc codes and
doing a lot better than we were doing
say two years ago or four years ago so
okay okay
so moving on to the code so the
hyperbolic surface codes um
yeah are are okay and one advantage that
they
they do have is that we can use uh this
the surface code decoding algorithms
that we have
because it's all it's just a surface
code um
but in order to do better in terms of
correcting errors
you might want to do something else and
so one option that's been suggested is
the
4d hyperbolic surface codes so these use
a similar idea to the surface codes
where you have
a lattice tiling in this case a
four-dimensional manifold
and it has to be a hyperbolic manifold
in order to get these
the same high rate that we did with
hyperbolic service code
um but because of the properties of 40
hyperbolic spaces
uh the distance is not log n it's n to
the epsilon
um where epsilon is some number between
zero and half
um and and so that's a good thing that's
much better at correcting errors in
principle
um but in practice we don't have
decoding algorithms that can take kind
of full advantage of that distance
there's an algorithm by my hastings that
it does decode these hybrid surface
codes
but it gives only kind of logical error
rate that's one over polynomial in it
just like the hyperbolic
the two-dimensional surface so that's
not a great candidate at the moment but
you know if somebody comes up with
with better decoding algorithms that
that might be
interesting again so then
one family of codes which i'm going to
talk about some more
is called expander codes and these have
turned out to be very promising
so they used a construction called the
hypergraph product instruction
um and they have good decoding
algorithms um
and they seem to have a reasonable
threshold for air correction
so that's um and they have high rate as
well so that's uh that's something that
that looks like it might be the correct
directing to go if we want to use
high rate ldpc codes um but i
i would also be remiss if i didn't
mention some of the major progress over
the past year
in ldpc codes which is that it used to
be
that we could only do no matter you know
two dimensions whatever dimensions we
couldn't do much better in terms of
distance
than with the surface code right the
surface code had a distance square root
of n
there were certain codes that had
existence that were known that had a
distance that was square root of n
times some polar log n factors
um but for a long long time that was all
it could that all could happen but in
the last year there's been a lot of
progress in getting beyond that
and um now we have codes that have
a distance and over login um
and uh that's that's probably still an
active area of research it would not be
at all surprising if that just gets up
to something that's
o of n um the problem is that these
codes are not suitable f
yet for what i want to do because um
they have low rate they're not
designed to to be um
to be high rate codes yet um but but the
fact that we made this progress
maybe means that the next step is to
find high rate codes that also have high
distance
and so those codes could potentially be
much better at correcting errors
than these expander codes or even in the
surface code
okay
so hypergraph product codes so what are
those well again i'm not going to get
into the technical detail but
basically it's a construction that takes
two classical codes
and from them it produces a quantum code
um
and so it's it's it's uh
uh some sort of product construction um
again i can't really say too much more
without going into more detail than
than i really want to um but the the
there's a couple of important things
about it so one of them is that if both
of the classical
codes that you use are ldpc codes so for
instance it's the
one ldp z code that used twice um then
the quantum code that you get is also an
ldpc code
with you know slightly higher um
numbers of qubits in each row versus the
number of classical bits in each row for
instance um
and the other thing is that the if the
rate
and the distance well if the rate of the
the
classical codes was good then the rate
of the quantum code will also be good
and the distance behaves in a less good
way but still not a horrible way
so in particular if you take an nkd
classical ldpc code and you take the
hypergraph product with itself
then you get a quantum code that has
n squared plus n minus k squared
physical qubits so order n squared
physical qubits
uh k squared logical qubits so
the the rate um is you know
order k squared over n squared which
is the square of the classical rate k
over n so if
if k over n was constant then k squared
over n squared is also constant
um and the distance however is just the
distance of the classical code
and so that means that the number of
errors that it can correct is no larger
than the classical code but the number
of qubits is increased
to n square so so even if the classical
code was a good code it had a constant
relative distance d over n was a
constant the quantum code is not it just
has a distance that order is square root
of n
um so um
nevertheless that's that turns out to be
good enough for these fault tolerance
purposes
um in order to to to have a threshold
and so uh so codes from this hypergraph
product construction
seem to be useful and so one particular
family of codes that that's received
some attention
is the quantum expander codes and so to
do that you take a classful expander
code
and um take the product with itself now
the classical expander codes are good
codes
so we get codes that have constant the
quantum codes that have constant rate
and that of distance square root of n
okay so so why is it enough to have a
distance squared of n
to correct errors because again if we
have
an error occurring on each qubit with
probability p
then we should have p times n errors
right
and that's more than the distance so why
can we correct
more errors in the distance well the
thing is that the distance tells you
about the worst case
error and these errors because they're
occurring randomly on different qubits
are typical errors um
and so if errors occur randomly this is
true and the surface code is also true
of general quantum ldpc codes
uh if it's if the error rate is low
enough below some percolation threshold
then the arrows will form small clusters
that are far apart from each other
and those clusters um
if again if you're if you're at a low
enough error rate will be small enough
that the code can correct them they'll
below the distance
of the code and because they're far
apart they don't really interact with
each other you don't get confused about
how to correct them so so
therefore it turns out that actually
general quantum ldpc codes have a
threshold
for typical errors provided the distance
is at least uh order log n
so that's why these um these hyperbolic
2d
surface codes are still useful even
though the distance is only log n
they can correct typical errors albeit
without
as much error suppression as a code with
a higher distance
so okay so but remember i said that the
error correction procedure itself has to
be fault tolerant
and one feature of that is that when you
measure a bit of the error syndrome you
might actually want to use local
constraints
to try to figure out where the error is
um
that measurement itself can be wrong
with some probability that's also kind
of
order p um so in order to compensate for
that we need a decoding algorithm
that can take that into account um and
that's one of the things that makes the
surface code decoding
hard um so uh
but but again you know with some sort of
um
at least in the surface code you can do
this by adding an extra dimension
you can say well the surface this is not
physically adding a dimension to the
code this is in your representation
of the the data that you're doing you
measure this thing from one so you
measure this thing from again you make
it again
and so you can make a kind of a
three-dimensional plot
of when and where you saw errors
and then a similar percolation argument
says oh again these have to form
clusters and therefore we can
correct those clusters figuring out
where both the syndrome errors were and
where the physical errors were
okay so in a in a quantum expander code
um we also have robust decoding and it's
actually
even better than the surface code and so
again
we have a um a percolation argument that
says
well errors form some clusters that are
well separated from each other
and we can treat each cluster separately
um but one property
of the expander codes is that well
the the the channel graph the the graph
that
tells you um connects between the parity
checks and the
the qubits is an expander graph and so
that means
that you know if you have a small
cluster of errors in your code
and you imagine adding some additional
errors around the outside make this
cluster a little bit bigger
well then the number of syndromes sync
from bits that are affected by this
is growing very rapidly as the syndrome
grows grows exponentially
and so what that means is that we can do
a kind of a rapid a rapid
fairly greedy algorithm that tries to
say well okay what happens if we flip
this bit
does the number of violated synchron
checks
increase or decrease if it decreases
well that's moving in the right
direction if it increases that's moving
the wrong direction
and because of this expansion property
um you're
by by looking at at the correct subsets
of of bits to flip you can make it
shrink
rather than grow and make the error
shrink rather than grow
provided these clusters are not too big
which is what you're guaranteed by this
particular percolation argument
so this is not just
an efficient decoding algorithm but it's
actually a better one in many ways than
the surface code
because in surface code you had to
measure this thing for many many times
in this case you could just measure it
once and while that's not enough to
completely decode because some of your
measurements will be wrong
it is enough to get you know a lot of
information about the errors
and to mostly eliminate them so that's
kind of a much more efficient
thing to do um
so so again this is a fairly recent
thing from the past few years
um that that that we've known that this
is possible
and there's some work trying to
understand well okay suppose we have an
expander
code a quantum expander code what
does it actually mean in terms of
numbers of how how well we can correct
errors what error rate
this has to be and it turns out that
the threshold for for correcting errors
is pretty good
um it's um it's on the order of a few
percent now that's not directly
comparable to this one percent threshold
that i i mentioned for the surface code
and the reason for that
is that the these calculations for for
the expander
graphs are done in a simplified model
sometimes called a
um oh what's it called sorry blanking on
the name
um anyway it's a simplified model where
you know
you have synchron bit errors and you
have physical errors
but you don't keep track of the total
number of gates involved in the circuit
whereas um and a phenomenological error
model sorry
and so the people who look at phenomenal
air models for this the surface code but
they're
higher they're like you know 10 orders
10
so it's it's like a little bit smaller
than surface code but not dramatically
smaller
um now the circuits and this is a cache
the circuits
to to do this correction are probably
more complicated because
the the the cats on these expander codes
are larger
than the checks in the surface code um
so in practice
the threshold would probably be a bit
smaller if you follow this all the way
through
but that hasn't really been calculated
yet so that's that's still an open
question
okay so um so the next thing i wanted to
talk about where there's also been some
progress
is a fault tolerant gaze for the surface
code design enough for surface code for
the expander codes
so um there's a variety of tricks for
the surface code
and some of these can kind of be
imitated for these expander codes
so um there's a bunch of a bunch of uh
gate constructions that work kind of
with arbitrary stabilizer codes
um and some of them are suitable and
some of them are not um
so for instance uh transversal gates
um is a i'm not gonna explain what that
is if you know what it is
uh that's fine but they're a very simple
way of doing fault tolerant gates
but um there's something that doesn't
work very well
um when you have a big block of of a
code that encodes many many logical
qubits
because what these transversal gates do
is they take a whole block and they do
some some gate that
um that does a single qubit gates or
interacts all this block with another
block
and then it does something to all the
logical qubits in the block and that's
not generally something we want to do
unless it's in some very specific uh
situation it's not something we want for
our general algorithm
um so we'll probably have to do
something else for most of the gays
and again there are things you can do
but one one recent progress
to try to keep the overhead of these of
these gate constructions down
is to do code deformation tricks which
are kind of
similar and inspired by those used for
surface codes
okay so um however those those use
uh just clifford group gate so that's a
set of gates that's non-universal
um so so we're gonna need additional
gates and as far as we know
the the best way to do that um is again
using magic states the state injection
which is
another standard um uh
fault hauling gate construction um
and one that's that's uh also used for
surface codes
okay but how can we do that and keep the
overhead down
well the thing is that in order to do
state injection you require a large
vancilla that's like the size of the
code block
okay and then you interact that
ancillary
uh block with the code block that you're
using
so in order to do that we're going to
need to create this
special state the magic state encoded in
a large code block
and of course at the beginning of the
computation we also need to create
a logical qubits logical code blocks
say in this state the logical state zero
so uh how can we do that well here's a
way it's probably not the best way but
it's a way that that does work
which is to use one of the other fault
tolerant protocols called concatenated
coding
and so what we do is we take some small
code
and we encode um
we encode the ancilla state that we want
in this small code so we take each qubit
of the ancilla
and encode it in one block of the small
code
um and then we take uh
each of those and encode them again
using say the same code okay and again
and again and again
and so now we have a code that uses many
many
uh qubits although again it's only some
polynomial in the log
of of n or the size of the
circuit that we need to make the
enceladus yeah i'm sorry we don't take
yeah what i said was wrong so um
we don't take the ancilla we don't take
the ancilla initially
we take we create logical zero states
this way and because we have a fault
tolerant protocol
the concatenated code then once it's
encoded we can create the ancilla state
on the concatenated code okay
and um once we've done that well now
we've created
uh the the encoded um
magic state or whatever state we need in
the ldpc code
and so now we can decode the
concatenated code we don't need it
anymore
and then we're left with the ancillary
state that we wanted
um so this is a big pin in the neck um
the overhead
as i said is n times poly log n um
n now is not doesn't have to be the
number of qubits in your whole quantum
computer
it's the number of physical qubits in
one code block
um and um so so
so that would be you know if we're doing
that for the whole
code we kind of ruin the overhead that
we were hoping to get
um because we'd be using the overhead of
the concatenated code rather than the
overhead
of the um of the
uh of the ldpc code so sorry i noticed
there was another question here so let's
see what that is
how can one perform gates fly code
informations without affecting multiple
qubits in a block in case we're
transversal gates we never
yeah okay so good answer a good question
um
so um the uh
the the answer is that you do affect
multiple qubits in a block
you affect um all the logs and qubits
but
um but if you're careful about how you
do it you
you get to control which ones you affect
um so for instance in the case of
surface codes
and it doesn't work exactly the same way
in the case of lgbc codes
you have you kind of localize physically
localize
your your logical qubits by having you
know holes you have a surface that has
some holes in it
and so for instance you can take these
holes and move them around each other
and then only the qubits associated with
those particular holes
uh have a gate done to them now if you
do some arbitrary deformation you will
be affecting the other qubits
and it turns out in the case of the ldpc
codes there's an element of that as well
um and uh but the
the upside is you have a wide enough
variety of deformations that you can do
that in principle you can do um gates
that will just affect single qubits
but it is an important problem in here
to figure out kind of explicitly how to
do that and that's something that hasn't
been done yet
okay so um so getting back to what i was
saying so
so we use the magic states to uh we we
we can create the magazine states using
this concatenated code procedure
but the that procedure itself has
substantial overhead
um but it has substantial overhead in
the size of a single block
so suppose instead of putting all of our
logic qubits in one
giant block of the code we break up
the computer into smaller blocks blocks
that are still large
so i'm going to use something that's um
a size k
over poly log k if there's k logical
qubits in the whole thing
um and each of those blocks
um has uses our ldpc code
and so it had so those blocks have a
pretty good rate because
they're still quite large um
and then the um
but then the overhead needed to make an
ancilla for one of these blocks
is k over poly log k times poly log
n which is again poly log k so the poly
logs cancel out
um if we were smart enough to pick a big
enough polynomial to log in the
denominator here
then we end up with something that's
um the total overhead to create one of
these ancillas
is is smaller or no at least
no bigger well i guess it has to be
bigger
than than a code a single code block but
it's smaller it's still
a little o of of n the total number of
physical qubits
that we needed for all the blocks so in
particular it's it's little o
of k over the weight so
um asymptotically the
size of this uh overhead of magma
scencilla is degradable
um but the catch for that is that we can
only make one at a time
or we'll do the scaling if we wanted to
do things in parallel
if we wanted to make many of these
densities one for each code block
then um we'd be back to having this
polylog
overhead and so we can't do that in this
procedure anyway
okay so that's that's the way that you
can still have low overheads at least in
the asymptotic pressure game
um but um but and use these ldpc codes
okay so um so
so what's the upshot of that well the
upshot um
is that uh if you have a code with the
following properties
so first of all it has to be a family of
codes that are low density parity check
codes
they need to have constant rate r as n
goes to infinity so there's bigger
bigger values uh bigger sizes of code
that
that um get you know better
not necessarily better and better rates
but rates that that don't get smaller
and smaller
um and that the values of n that
work for this code are not too rare so
that you can always find ones about the
right size for your computation
um and they're pretty good correcting
typical errors uh even
when there's um when there's a syndrome
errors so in
in this uh robust error correction uh
scenario um and
when they do that then the logical error
rate goes to zero as
as n goes to infinity and let's say it
goes as one over
g of n some function g of n and then
finally there's an efficient classical
decoding algorithm for these codes
well then the upshot and expander codes
by the way have all of these properties
that's kind of what i've been
been discussing um so the upside is that
there exists
um a threshold for for computations that
are
of size uh literal o of t of k
um computations and the overhead is is
arbitrarily close to one over r
um so what's it saying is that
is that asymptotically you can create
uh ldpc based fault tolerant protocols
that have a constant overhead that don't
have an overhead that grows with the
size of computation but one that
that stays the same um
and so to be a little more precise here
um
if you have a code family that's
satisfying the first four conditions
um then you pick some alpha less than
one
and uh if you have a a circuit
family that you want to perform that
that
uses um k logical qubits and f of k
locations where f of k is a little of g
of k to the alpha um and you want to
achieve
an overhead within a factor a constant
factor eta
of the rate of the code and a logical
error probability epsilon
then there's a threshold error rate
which depends on this area that you want
to achieve
and the threshold psi is k0 and if you
have computations that are bigger than
k0
and scale as f of k then
if if the error rate per gate or time
step is below this threshold value p sub
t
then there exists a fall tolerance
simulation using the the ldpc
family that has logical error rate less
than epsilon and overhead
less than eta over r so it can be a
constant and it can be
a constant that's arbitrarily close to
the rate of the family
of codes that you're using okay
and then property five is needed so that
the
the the fault tolerance simulation that
you're doing
only uses a polynomial amount of
classical computation which is obviously
desirable as well
okay so um
so uh so now i've said a lot about ldpc
codes and i think it's time to
stop and and think again which is better
surface codes or ldpc codes and again
there's no answer to that
it's uh there's advantages to want to
advance against the other
so um so right now based on the state of
the art
now um ldpc codes have one big advantage
um they have a low overhead compared to
service codes
um that's at least in the asymptotic
regime
and moreover it's not just that they
have a low overhead but there's no
theoretical limit to the overhead the
overhead
by picking an appropriate family of
codes can be made arbitrarily close to
one
that there's very few extra physical
qubits per logical qubit
um it depends on how big on the
computation you want to get and how hard
you're willing to work
uh say to get the error rate down um
however um again if you're stuck with
the current
uh knowledge of ldpc codes well the
threshold error rate
while not you know horribly bad is
probably going to be worse than surface
codes
um we don't know how to do this with
local gates in a finite number of
dimensions and that seems like something
that's probably very hard to do
um we don't know how to do it with a
fully parallel circuit
so you're really if you have a well
paralyzed
algorithm then you'd end up trading off
space for time
at the moment i think that's a good
trade-off because a
number of qubits is a is a big
constraint in existing systems
but it's clearly something that's not
completely desirable
um and right now we could really do a
lot
better with the gate implementations the
ones that we have
that that that we know they work can be
pretty complicated
um and some of these new ones with
co-defamation are not very explicit
and so that needs to be to be worked out
better
um but you know this is with the current
state of the art and i don't think
that's a fair comparison because surface
codes have been around for a lot longer
and they've received a lot of attention
a lot of optimization
and you know you know five years ago
ldpc codes i mean i had shown that this
constant rate thing was possible
um but most of the stuff i talked about
today
just was not known we didn't know even
families of codes that could
could satisfy all those conditions one
through five we do now
um we certainly didn't know what the
threshold was going to be um
and what we still don't know we have we
have an idea that it's not too bad
um and so many many things have been
done in the past few years and
so uh i i think that will continue to be
true
and we definitely need more work and so
in that spirit i just want to end with a
list of
of i think open questions that are all
like really interesting and really
important um
so one very big one is suppose you run
like a full fault tolerant protocol
using ldp z code
you count all the gates and they are
correcting procedures you count the
gates
to do logical gates and all that other
stuff what is the threshold that you get
for that and how does it compare to the
surface codes um and of course you know
that's not just a single answer it's
going to depend
on continuous optimizations of all these
procedures
um next open question so are there good
quantum ldpc codes so that is other
codes where
the the relative rate k over n and the
distance d over n are both
constants as n gets large um and
you know a year ago a lot of people
might have guessed that there wasn't
because
we were so unsuccessful at high finally
high distance codes but there's been a
lot of progress in the past year and and
maybe soon uh we'll be able to say yes
sex codes do exist um and here's the
thing
is that um there's a there's a
a bound for channel capacity so if you
guys will this is not fault tolerance if
you just want to transmit
our correct uh error corrected qubits
over
noisy channel um there's a bound coming
from random coding
that's the best you can do using random
coding but it turns out that quantum
codes
can beat that random coding bound called
the hacking bound
by at least a little bit um
and they do it using this phenomenon of
degeneracy that i mentioned
uh you have different errors that do the
same thing to the code and that lets you
kind of
squeeze more error correction capability
in some circumstances into your code
um and so quantum lgbt codes they
they are very degenerate codes they have
a lot of instances of different errors
doing the same thing
so it's a really interesting question of
if can you can you come up with quantum
ldbc codes
that beat the hacking bound for for
channel capacity and
high rate ldpc goes in particular maybe
they can do it by a lot that's this
the upper bounds are not very tight or
at least they're far away from the
hashing valve
um okay so the next question um
the the protocols that i mentioned that
have these complicated gate
constructions
they only show big overhead improvements
for large
uh circuits so are there are there good
protocols for small
uh circuits in particular circuits that
we might want to implement in the next
you know five to ten years
um so that's that's would be really
interesting because that would let us
you know get out of the nisk error and
into the fault tolerant
quantum computation errors sooner um
and uh so another another question is
decoding algorithms
um you know we would like to make them
faster of course uh
the the current one is fast it has it's
not it's not too too bad
it has um it has this single shot
property
where you don't have to measure this
thing from many many times um
but it probably could be made faster and
it might i mean it can be improved in
terms of the earth threshold and so one
of those papers that i
i mentioned was was doing that by
combining it with some blues propagation
ideas
um and gate constructions clearly this
is something that we need a lot more
work on there's just been a little bit
um can we get specialized gate
constructions that don't don't require
too much overhead
um and then these questions the next two
questions is less clear
whether it's possible or not but can we
can we get around this problem with
parallelization
if we come up with better gait
constructions maybe we can do it in a
way that lets
us preserve parallel parallelism in the
original algorithm
and finally is there some way to
to use these ldpc codes in um
nearest neighbor gates in constant
dimensions or is the overhead of getting
the faraway qubits to talk to each other
going to be so large that we use the
lose the benefits of having these high
rate ldpc codes
um if we can't do that well the ldc
codes are still interesting but they're
only interesting for architectures
that allow you to easily communicate
between far away q events
things like photons you can do that um
but they'll be less good
for things like superconducting two bits
where it's it's
you know preferable to have neighboring
gates talk to each other neighboring
qubits talk to each other by gates
um so yeah that's all i wanted to say
so thanks great thanks a lot uh
danielle that's that's really uh very
interesting can i let me ask you a
quick question and then turn it over to
um for everyone else uh so
um you know in terms of in terms of
using expanders
expander codes there's there's always
this question how do you ever get the
qubits to talk to each other is that is
that what you meant by
embedding them in finite dimensions and
so what how how
in what way would this uh you know with
this work and scale and so on
um right so um
so so getting them to talk to each other
uh i
i mean usually i mean they talk to each
other by gates and the question is
which qubits need to have gates
that interact the two of them directly
right and so typically if you have a
check operator
then all the qubits involved in a check
arbiter have to talk to the same qubit
because um at some point that
information from them has to get
together
now it could be that they talk to the
same qubit before they interact
you know where you have some enceladus
and you create some many cuban cell and
you send it all over
um but to make that entangled and solid
they all those qubits had to interact as
well
so you need some kind of of way of doing
that and if they're physically near each
other
then that's much easier than if they're
physically far apart from each other
so that's what i mean by embedding in in
two or three dimensions is you say
well let me take the connectivity graph
of the qubits here
and say which qubits have to talk to its
other qubits and try to embed that graph
in two dimensions or even three
dimensions if you can make a
three-dimensional
physical architecture right so so and
that was my question so once
once you take into account the embedding
of the expander in your local graph
what happens to the overheads
um uh yes
i don't think anybody's worked that out
in the case of these ldpc codes
um now i could say that it
um you know it's not it's not impossible
that something could work i mean
i don't know how to do it certainly but
if you think about concatenated codes
which was
you know this kind of old-fashioned
quality protocol um they're not ldpc
codes you know every
every qubit in principle has to talk to
many many other qubits
but um because they have this
hierarchical structure
you have some things that you can make
local which is the lower level codes
and then you have some higher level
structures which require longer distance
communication but it doesn't have to
happen very often
so um it could be that if you come up
with some kind of clever way
of stratifying the checks in this ldpc
code
you'll have some ones that can be local
and have to be done frequently and some
ones that you still need but
can be done more infrequently and maybe
in that case you could do it without any
extra overhead
but again that's just pure speculation
there's no particular reason to believe
that's possible
and in in addition to uh overhead
it sounds like what you're saying is
that it could also
help you uh deal with you have to do the
error correction often enough and you're
saying you could
you could defer some of it that's right
so you have to do some error correction
frequently but maybe you don't have to
do
all the error correction all the time
okay so i see a hand from ike
uh who i guess is on the panel hi daniel
um
maybe this is a quick question i i was
amusing about
finding ldpc codes or quantum ones
classical ldpc codes as i understand
are are linear codes obtained from
sparse
bipartite graphs and i was wondering if
it's
a given that quantum ldpc codes also
must be linear or stabilizer codes or
could you take
two classical otpc codes and combine
them in a way which is not going to give
you a stabilizer code but still
is a useful quantum ldpc code um
maybe i mean again i don't know how to
do actors
but um as as i said in response to
ronnie's question people have have
thought about you know ground states of
hamiltonians
uh local hamiltonians as codes and you
know
maybe maybe using that picture you could
some find some way of combining them i
don't know
maybe i was thinking of like the cws
construction
cultural stabilized states um
yeah maybe that might be another
framework for doing it um
yeah i mean it's not it's not obvious
how to do that but but it
possibly yeah nothing rules it out as
far as you know
no no i mean i in terms of ruling stuff
out i'm not sure there's really anything
that's known
that's i mean obviously there are some
limits right we have we do
we have limits on stabilizer codes and
finite dimensions for instance but
you know once they start to be
non-stabilizer codes the bounds are much
weaker
right great thanks thanks for a nice
talk
um let's see and i see in the chat
a question from ronald the wolf um
can you say a bit about correlated
errors on multiple qubits when does the
synthology of the threshold do
so um so if you have correlated errors
on say pairs of qubits the threshold
theorem will still work
um and uh i mean it's still not a good
thing because the value of the threshold
will be lower
um but as long as you have correlations
that only affect kind of a constant
number of qubits at once
then you're fine because you know you
can always get that same constant number
of qubits
happening with a constant probability
right um
because you know you have five qubits
what's the probability of all five of
those qubits going wrong
even if it's independent that's like p
to the phi which is a constant because p
is constant um
and so it only really starts to be a
problem if you have
uh large numbers of qubits and really
they have to scale with the system size
faster than log n that that have a
correlated occurrence where
they all go wrong at the same time with
say a constant probability
and once that starts to happen then
you're out of the regime before the
threshold theorem works
if it's a very very specific error model
you might still be able to do something
but in general error correction is not
going to work and photograph it's not
going to work
so so is is it does it relate to the
percolation bound then
is is that what one should be thinking
of as the
as um
yeah probably that's fair i mean
um i mean what so what i was saying is a
kind of a general thing that's not about
ldpc codes it's about our correcting
codes and fault tolerance in general
um but if you're dealing with ldpc codes
yeah i mean so your your correlations
are kind of having multiple things
occurring at once
i mean if they're if they're localized
yeah and so
yeah todd brown is saying this in in the
cat if they're localized
then then it might be okay um but
but if the if the
if the cluster of errors that occurs at
once is very big
then of course your your clusters and
the percolation
will be very big as well and that will
kind of overwhelm your code's ability to
correct
okay another question in the two and uh
todd in practice as you mentioned we may
not need to scale up to blocks of
unlimited size
if lloyd's rates are low enough that a
moderate uh size code blocks a very low
rate of incorrect blur
you could just okay this is this is i
guess a comment
rather than a question could just scale
up our computations by using multiple
copies of that block instead of going to
larger blocks
could ease or not eliminate the locality
conference that's right
okay let's see looks like we have a
question from amina
uh yes so um it's also maybe just a
comment but
uh there was a question that you
mentioned about density evolution
and i i didn't even see it but so
uh what density evolution is is sort of
a self-decision decoding so if you
uh if it's hard so in a classical world
you have zeros advanced and as the
algorithm progresses
some of these zeros get flipped into
once and uh hopefully you converge to a
correct
string of bits now uh
uh if you have a soft beliefs then you
have some density evolution you believe
that one bit is
one with probability one third another
is one with probability two threats and
so on
as as the algorithm progresses this uh
density evolution becomes
you firmly believe into something right
so it becomes the response
so is that even possible for quantum
well so yeah so this is the sort of
thing that doesn't work uh if you
if you just take it like that in the
quantum case and the reason is
because these degeneracies effectively
create correlation
with the errors on different qubits
right so
um because you know errors on these two
qubits are the same as errors on these
two qubits
you can't kind of treat them
independently you have to treat them
collectively
and so the the algorithm that i
mentioned for the expander codes does
this it looks at
clusters that are kind of the size of
the the correlations
and tries to all the possibilities there
and since there is an ldpc code they're
constant size
clusters but if you look at just
individual qubits
that's when that's when you get into
these cycles and it doesn't it doesn't
convert anyone
so there might be something like that
that works um some of these better
algorithms kind of combine
this um this small group with belief
propagation type things or
or this sort of density evolution and
uh certainly the ideas are
are useful but you have to modify them
to make them work with these quantum
codes
thanks okay great so
let's see if the if there aren't any
other quick questions and
um let's um
let's thank daniel again for a fantastic
talk and then
um we'll meet up at gathertown so uh if
you'd like to
meet i put put the link in the chat
so great uh thanks everybody and thank
you
daniel thank you